it's a great question today that we
ponder
was it worth it a couple of things to
remember about air power before we begin
in earnest
one is that there was an enormous
transformation
between its inaugural appearance in 1914
and world war one when
pilots and biplanes shot revolvers
at each other in less than 30 years
about 25 years 24 years
at the outbreak in september first of
1939
and world war ii we had monoplanes and
the speeds had increased from
100 miles an hour to nearly 300 and
people were firing about seven to 800
shots per minute on machine guns
sometimes right through the propeller
sometimes on the wings and they were
carrying bomb loads in the case of
fighter bombers of 500 to a thousand
pounds and bombers even
far greater so there was a miraculous
transformation
in the role of air power and that
created
our architects of air power so to speak
in the european countries and in the
united states as well
billy mitchell duet weaver in germany
and they were so enthralled by this new
weapon
that they made a series of astounding
predictions
and so much that prime minister stanley
baldwin in the late 1930s said
in despair the bomber will always get
through and it was almost as if
assets at sea navies
and assets on the ground infantry were
going to be
secondary or even irrelevant the war
would take place
up in the air the problem with that is
nobody lives up in the air nobody eats
in the air nobody
can fly we don't have wings so what
you're doing is transferring label
labor and capital from the ground up
into the air and there has to be a
purpose for that
and the purpose had to be either air
superiority
or air supremacy and by that i mean
your air forces had to beat the other
person's air forces for the prime reason
that they could then direct their assets
to where things really mattered on the
ground
taking cities or territory or killing
people or capturing them on the ground
if you couldn't do that and you only
achieved air parity
then both sides were sort of wasting
their time in an irrelevant
theater so the purpose was to build more
planes and better planes and train
better pilots
to destroy the enemy's assets or at
least weaken them so you had air
superiority
and then the holy grail was air
supremacy
that meant that you could put your
assets up in the air
they could fly over the enemy's
territory destroy his cities
or his armies on the ground and they
would be invulnerable because you had
destroyed the enemy's ability to fight
back in the air
and that was pretty much the theory of
air power in world war
ii it's a great question today that we
ponder
was it worth it the people say it didn't
work it was 80 000 people weren't worth
it
we lost over 5 000 bomber planes we
spent 40 percent of our military budget
and yet german uh industrial production
kept going
the defenders of air power said well we
had to we had to make the necessary
investments we lost
men and materiel learning how to fly in
the proper
formation how to have the proper fighter
the proper fighter tactics the proper
radar
but once we learned that we destroyed
germany's
industrial production and it's not quite
accurate to say
it continued to increase in terms of
vehicle or aircraft production because
germany really wasn't mobilized until
albert speer
the czar of german industry took control
of the economy in
late 1943 once he did that
we were destroying the increase in
production
and spears planned economy was not
sustainable so even though it increased
it did not increase at the rate that it
would otherwise have
had we not been bombing around the clock
the united states lost about 400
000 dead through accidents disease and
combat
britain lost a little bit fewer and yet
defeated a far
more formidable enemy than was true in
world war
one in other words germany japan and
italy were far more powerful allies and
enemies than had been cut the imperial
uh german army of world war one and how
did they do that and how did they lose
only about
two to three percent of their entire
military forces and the answer was
sea power and air power did one thing
they avoided the need
to land in europe at the very beginning
of 1940 41 in the case of british
and the united states and 42 or 43 in
japan
in other words we did not do what we did
in 1917 the case of america and the
british in 1914
we did not bleed white our ground forces
to take the enemy capital and knock the
enemy out of the war
we bombed them into submission and
therefore precluded an invasion
of japan entirely and we precluded an
invasion of europe until we were ready
to do it in june 1944.
so the ultimate verdict i think on air
power
was it was very costly it did not work
too well in 41 42 and 43
but the allies gained the lessons and
achieved air
superiority and eventually air supremacy
that by 1944-1945
it saved thousands of lives and it was
one of the greatest successes of world
war
ii
thank you for watching we hope you're
enjoying our highlight series
and invite you to explore our complete
course on the second world wars
all of hillsdale college's online
courses are free
and for everyone who loves to learn